It's almost become an orthodoxy for
people to say,
oh,
magna Carta is a bit of an irrelevant
piece of Gulf.
Uh,
I don't think it is irrelevant Gulf.
I think it's very important not for what
it meant in 1215 but for the symbol that
it became and for the significance that
it acquired as part of the common law.
And to give you what seems to me to be a
good example,
a blackstone's commentaries on the law
of England,
the classic 18th century text of English
common law principles published in 1765
blackstone when considering the notion
of absolute fundamental rights under the
English constitution takes us his
starting point.
Magna Carta,
which he calls that great charter
obtained at the point of a sword and he
identifies from magna Carta three
fundamental rights,
which actually I think you can discern
in clause 39 the right to life or
personal autonomy,
the right to liberty and the right to
private property.
Because what clause 39 says is that you
cannot apply force to somebody.
You cannot exile them.
You cannot take their property and you
cannot imprison them without judgment of
their peers or without the application
of the law.
And from those,
from that principal,
he identifies those three fundamental
rights.
And then he says this,
he says,
in order for those three fundamental
rights to have any purchase,
they must be supported by ancillary
rights.
And he identifies three of those as
well.
The first is the rights and privileges
of parliament.
The second is the limitations on the
royal prerogative and on the executive.
And the third is the right of access to
justice and the significance of close,
close,
40 to no man will we sell,
delay or deny justice is that that
encapsulates the notion of access to
justice so that what you have,
I think a magna Carta is the kernel of
two basic constitutional principles.
Firstly,
the rule of law and the protection of
fundamental rights.
And secondly,
the need for access to court to support
the rule of law.
And that concept runs through the common
law.
You can see it in modern case law,
important cases like with them about
access to justice,
medical justice,
and whether you're actually citing magna
Carta and I ice eyesight,
blackstone's commentaries.
And I've done it in many cases and it
gets much more purchase with a common
law judge in many occasions.
And the Human Rights Act does because
blackstone's speaks to the breast of the
judges in the common law.
And the origin of those principles
ultimately is a magna Carta.
And if you look at a case like the are
raw we decision that said that the
common law would not tolerate secret
courts.
That is a passionate declaration by the
Supreme Court of the importance of basic
principles of open justice,
uh,
which ultimately have their origin,
not in Magna Carta itself,
but in Magna Carta as a symbol as it's
developed over the following 800 years.